with pride being celebrated around the
world this month I thought it would be
fun to pick my top 5 LGBTQ movies of all
time now these are just my personal
favorite films and it was really hard to
choose just 5 some honorable mentions
before we begin Brokeback Mountain The
Birdcage Hedwig in the Angry Inch blue
is the warmest color The Kids Are
Alright
and love Simon all of those films are
fantastic movies with LGBTQ
representation but it's time to get the
countdown started kicking things off at
number 5 is moonlight the 2016 film was
adapted from a play and revolves around
a young black boy and three crucial
stages in his life which includes the
meeting of a local drug dealer who takes
him under his wing at some point you got
to decide for yourself we can't let
nobody make that decision for you the
movie is so beautifully acted by an
all-black cast and deals with black gay
identity which is something we really
haven't seen explored so exceptionally
Wow
I see you ain't it film won three
Academy Awards including Best Picture
after a little bit of unfortunate
confusion in at number four on my list
is call me by your name the 2017 film is
based off a novel of the same name and
as brutally honest beautiful and a
coming-of-age story about sexuality love
and heartbreak the movie has standout
performances by Timothy sha'lame and
Armie Hammer and was both a critical and
commercial success call me by your name
is so perfect it will no doubt be an
iconic LGBTQ film for generations to
come
shouldn't said anything just pretend you
never do
[Music]
number three is milk the 2008 film
starred Sean Penn in an academy
award-winning role as real-life
politician Harvey Milk who helped break
down political barriers and fought for
LGBTQ and human rights you'll be the
first openly gay man elected to major
office Society can't exist without the
family we're not against that can two
men reproduce no but God knows we keep
trying why do I love milk
well milk is a history lesson it reminds
us of those who helped pave the way for
some of the rights and freedoms the
LGBTQ community has today beyond that it
is still so relevant with the current
political climate it reminds us to
continue to use our voices to fight for
our rights and freedom you have an issue
it's more than an issue this is our
number two on my list is the movie but
I'm a cheerleader I watched this film
when I was struggling with my own
identity 20 years ago I can't believe it
was 20 years ago and it remains one of
my favorites the film stars natasha
Lyonne whose parents and friends have
decided that she is gay and they plan an
intervention and send her off to a boot
camp called true directions which is
actually a conversion therapy can uh
theny about conversion therapy and it
really is still a shockingly relevant
topic today but the movie does hit on
self-acceptance and it takes a few jabs
at those who challenge the queer
community although the movie was panned
by critics when it was released it has
become a true cult classic and it has
standout performances by Natasha and of
course mamma Roo
I get good grades I go to church I'm a
cheerleader
[Music]
along to righteousness Megan that's a
battlefield of temptation out there and
you're gonna have to fight and in the
number one position on my list Paris is
burning the 1990 documentary is my
favorite of all time and if you haven't
seen it you need to watch it tonight my
name is Angie extravagant and I am the
mother of the house of extravaganza I'm
Lily ninja the mother of the house of
ninja hard bad we come out to
assassinate the dock is full of queer
history exploring New York City's drag
ball culture and it tells the stories of
many people involved within the scene it
explores race wealth gender and
sexuality it is uplifting yet
heartbreaking and it is an eye-opening
look at queer and trans communities of
color in the 80s if you use the word
shade in your vocabulary this is where
it came from
in 2016 the dock was selected for
preservation in the US National Film
registry for being culturally
historically and aesthetically
significant yeah it sure is we owe a lot
to the fearless people in this film I'm
gonna be saying it we're sick we're
crazy and some of them think that we are
the most gorgeous special things on
earth
[Music]
so do you agree with my picks what are
your own top 5 LGBTQ movies do you think
we're seeing great LGBTQ representation
in media so far in 2019 let me know in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page